Beatriz is ordering pizzas for party
each pizza is cut into 12 pieces Beatriz
wants to have enough pizza so that each
person can have four pieces can have
four pieces and 16 people will be at the
party a lot of information in this
problem if Beatriz buy seven pizzas so
you buy seven pizzas how many extra
pieces will there be after each person
eats four pieces so to do this let's
think about how many total pieces she
will have and then let's think about how
many total pieces will be eaten by the
16 people and then we'll figure out how
much that she had extra so first let's
think about how many total pieces and I
encourage you to pause the video and try
to figure it out yourself she has she
ordered seven pizzas how many total
pieces are there going to be well you
have seven pizzas seven that's the
number of pizzas number of pizzas and if
you have if you have 12 pieces per pizza
you multiply by 12 to get the total
number of pieces so this is number of
pieces pieces per pizza and seven times
12 is equal to 84 total pieces total
total pieces so that's how many pieces
she's got now let's think about how many
get eaten by the 16 people so you have
16 people 16 that's the number of people
number of people and this little symbol
that's shorthand for number 16 people
and they each eat four pieces so sixteen
people times four pieces per person so
number of pieces per person pieces per
per person 16 times 4 is 64 so that's 64
not 84 64 64 pieces are eaten are eaten
by the 16
so how much does she have left over well
if you start with 84 pieces and 64 get
eaten 84 minus 64 is 20 so you have you
have we deserve a drum roll now you have
20 pieces 20 pieces that are going to be
or 20 extra pieces after everyone eats
their share